[Music]
he's here
cyrano
the love triangle between cyrano
christian and roxanne is probably one of
the original love triangles this is such
a beloved story roxanne
it's a real throwback to a real hurt on
your sleeve feeling love
does that mean nothing to you
children need love adults need money
i wrote an adaptation of the roof stand
sereno de bergerac and joe wright came
and saw the play
i guess it spoke to me in terms of it
being a story about feeling
worthy of love i am madly in love this
man i love is a god in your regiment
these characters love tortures them
woman like roxanne wants weight romance
poetry
[Music]
so syria knows brilliant plan is to get
christian to send letters that he's
written to roxanna i will make you
eloquent while you make me handsome
it has everything in common with what we
live in today because
they're not living in reality he was
setting up a false profile of himself
it's fascinating your exact opposites in
style christian is
passionate you are coded the original
play by us filled with incredibly long
speeches the day it was born there from
the day it was born
there there
what if all those speeches were songs
what does it feel like to slow dance in
sunlight with someone you love
music was composed by members of the
band the national music is really the
heartbeat of the piece and the lyrics
are so expressive
it's so beautiful
[Music]
we wanted to bring a kind of originality
to the characters
[Music]
it felt so modern in the sense that we
all find faults and being able to
communicate how we feel about each other
they all just really want
love
i hope people come away
with a renewed sense of love
and beauty
and a resolution to tell those that they
love that they do love them
[Music]
you